the Syrian government's alleged chemical
weapons attack on its own people is
creating new tension between Western
powers and Syria's ally Russia President
Trump tweeted this week that the
us-russia relationship is quote worse
now than it has ever been and that
includes the cold war CBS News
correspondent and co-host of Showtime's
the circus Alex Wagner traveled to
Moscow to see how the younger generation
of Russians use the tensions I told her
what they thought about the so-called
new cold war and shared their opinions
on of Americans when I say America what
is the first word that pops into your
mind from Trump okay Aerosmith Aerosmith
yeah probably McDonald's McDonald's yeah
but I think about McDonald's all the
time Stars and Stripes
American pop culture and everything and
probably like comic books Liberty those
are pretty positive happy images of
America and yet in the news today we
read that America and Russia are in a
new Cold War I totally disagree with
that I don't think that that's right
thing to isolate ourselves from the
outer world especially from America
because America is one of the leading
countries in the world my point of view
is like that those are just wonderful
topics for journalists that's it the
political decisions that are made right
now they are destructive for all spheres
for a life I think both countries are
led by very aggressively oriented people
I'd say do you think one side is more to
blame than the other both sides are to
be blamed so I respect Trump he does his
job
I respect Putin he does his job but I do
my job and don't think I'm not an expert
in bullet in politics what is most
intriguing to you about the United
States right now a lot of media says
that we have with this huge propaganda
in Russia maybe it's true but I think
the surprising thing for me is that
American people are more vulnerable to
any kind of even small propaganda for
example if I look at your camera and
say I live in Russia and I just love put
in because he's the greatest communist
of all time your audience is gonna go
like oh my god congra is so terrible
poor Russia but I know for sure they
don't know that Russia is not a
communist country at all do you believe
that when you hear in the American press
that the Russians had something to do
with the election
that sounds really funny to me because
wow I don't think that Russia would
would have done that I don't think that
is the job of the media nowadays to say
the truth it's mostly emotional I mean
if we have the media sensational not
Arab emotion exactly and then to react
to the media from from from other
media's around the world so do you feel
that's true for Russian media as well
yes all media yes exactly
do you think Putin has been in power too
long yes because sometimes I'm feeling
that he's becoming a bit inadequate and
adequate yeah and probably he stops
understanding what he wants what he's
doing and this is frightening for such a
level of authority I disagree with him
on many points yes but mostly satisfied
with the current political system yes
how are you different than the older
generation people who were born in the
Soviet Union
they didn't have a chance to travel
around the world we had this chance
because the borders are open and the
Western pop culture coming to us as
Russians do you feel isolated for
serious still got YouTube we watch CBS
watch Marvel will watch HBO our
favorites series is like Game of Thrones
right no you cannot isolate us because
we got money and we got we can grab a
ticket and visit you if you want but we
are ok here right for serious Alex
Wagner is with us at the table so
interesting to hear their perspectives
and certainly on Trump did they feel as
free and open to talk about their own
leader President Putin you know there's
a real sense of defiance that I got from
not just the Russian Millennials I spoke
with but Russians on the street
I spoke with they you know Russian state
propaganda has pushed its citizens to
believe that sanctions are having no
effect that Russia is as strong as it
ever has been and I feel like some of
that has trickled down I mean and these
kids feel like almost resistant to the
idea that they are somehow marginalized
in all of this Russian nationalism is a
huge part of Putin's rise what he wants
to deliver them it's not communism it's
not ideology of collectivism as much as
it was in the past do you see that
nationalism that they rallied to that
and that that's the connection between
Putin and the next generation absolutely
I mean the ones that respect guten
respect strength more than anything else
right you heard of shades of concern
about the authoritarianism but there
were spawned to the the projection of
strength and in that way they respond to
Trump as well but they also think
whatever you do in America we can copy
or do better one student said you know
you have your iPhone's and your
blockchains and you have your
innovations and we enjoy them and then
we'll make them better that is that is
that is the a disciple of Putin speaking
yeah all right Alex thank you so much
thank you and you can see Alex and more
of her reporting when the circus returns
for season 3 at air Sunday night on
Showtime a division of CBS